we first met the barkers back in the
summer
sarah who has asthma had been seriously
ill with kovid
is that okay good but when she tested
positive for antibodies
she'd assumed there'd be her protective
cloak against
further infection now she's not so sure
new research shows around a quarter of
people lose their antibodies
within three months now you can see a
line across you
i could still have them but i'm
certainly going to be
treating it now as if i haven't got
antibodies i think
yeah to be on the safe side because why
why put yourself at risk
you know if i do have asthma i don't
want to risk
getting it again scientists from
imperial college london who randomly
tested thousands of people
found that when lockdown was lifted in
the summer six percent of the population
had antibodies
by the start of the second wave in early
september it was just
four point four percent it falls far
short of what would be needed for herd
immunity
to create a fire break and stop the
virus spreading between
50 and 60 percent of the population
would have to be immune
the researchers say is more likely
people will get covered repeatedly
the bad news is that for the seasonal
coronaviruses that cause between 20 and
of common colds every year there are
four of those
and it's clear that we get reinfected
with those throughout our lives
so it wouldn't be surprising if this
sars cov2 that the cause of covid is a
virus that behaves like its cousins
and can re-infect people after one or
two years
but other scientists argue herd immunity
is still possible that
other parts of the immune system could
still be active even if
undetectable with current tests there
are very
very few reports of second infections
with it which suggests that once you've
had an infection
you do have protection at least for a
while so i would suggest that the
situation is significantly better that
there are fewer people
um vulnerable than the 90 odd percent
that this would suggest
it's far from clear what this means for
a vaccine
on one hand immunizations for some other
diseases
actually trigger stronger protection
than natural infection but others need
regular boosters to keep up immunity
and we won't know which it will be for
covid until a vaccine
is in widespread use thomas more sky
news